since lemonade bee's road to renaissance
has been a busy one
who could forget beyonce's stunning
coachella set in 2018 b became the first
black woman to headline the festival and
it marked her first performance since
giving birth to twins sir and roomie
carter
a celebration of
fans got a glimpse into the making of
beachella a year later in the netflix
stock homecoming
my mind was not there my mind wanted to
be with my children
what people don't see is the sacrifice
after coachella beyonce and jay-z
embarked on their second tour together
and billboard ranked on the run two as
the third highest grossing tour in 2018
raking in over 253 million dollars but
who could have guessed that we'd next
year beyonce like we've never heard her
before
simba
is that really you
in 2019 beyonce was the voice of adult
nala in the live-action remake of the
lion king she also gifted us a companion
soundtrack that in 2020 would become the
disney plus visual black is king
[Music]
that's where we got a rare glimpse of
the twins and of their eldest blue ivy
who was featured in brown skin girl
[Music]
the music video earned the then
nine-year-old her first grammy in 2021.
but not to be outdone blue's mom made
history of her own that same night the
grammy goes to
[Applause]
[Music]
beyonce at the 63rd annual awards
beyonce became the most awarded artist
in grammy's history after winning her
28th and as if that wasn't enough by
2022 beyonce would earn her first oscar
nomination queen b held core opening
this year's oscars with the first ever
performance of be alive from the movie
king
[Music]
sitting richard top of the world again
[Music]